was passiert jetzt ich bin heute morgen
aufgewacht und tramper präsident und die
welt brennt noch nicht was ist los alle
sagen die welt müsste eigentlich brennt
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video in
dem ich heute über donald trump reden
möchte es gibt sicher einige die sich
denken okay wer zur hölle ist anschauen
wenn sie zeitung nicht gelesen haben
warum soll ich das persönlich
interessiert was juckt mich dass das ist
wahrscheinlich irgendwo politiker jetzt
auch noch den vereinigten staaten das
ist doch total unbedeutend man muss ich
sagen nein leute es ist nicht so dass
donald trump präsident wurde ist ein
sehr sehr sehr wichtiges ereignis in der
weltgeschichte würde ich sagen und
deswegen möchte ich gerne in diesem
video darüber reden übrigens ich werd
nebenbei bis in minecraft zocken das
heißt wenn euch knie ich denke da bloß
kein bock drauf aber das thema
interessiert mich wenn ihr einfach das
handy irgendwie neben an den rand legen
und rennt essen zähneputzen so erst mal
vorneweg ich bin student ich bin kein
politikexperte ich studiere und politik
sondern wirtschaftswissenschaften aber
ich habe mich in letzter zeit bis mit
dem thema beschäftigt und glaubt dass es
ein sehr spannendes thema ist und das
ist auch sehr sehr viele leute in
deutschland betrifft erst mal vorneweg
einige leute wenn sie wahrscheinlich
frage ok donald trump im titel wer zur
hölle ist donald trump oder wenn sie
wissen wird das irgend so ein typ aus
den vereinigten staaten wenn sich fragen
okay was juckt mich das jetzt was mit
deutschland passiert dass es irgendeinen
gut in den vereinigten staaten warum
soll ich mir das anschauen warum soll
ich mir an was wird dazu zu sagen
die erklärung dafür ist relativ einfach
donald trump wurde gestern abend zum
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
gewählt die präsidentschaftswahl der
vereinigten staaten hat gestern abend
stattgefunden und wenn man sich das
nicht sowieso schon denken kann vom
namen her
das ist ein sehr sehr wichtiges ereignis
was eigentlich die ganze welt betrifft
und damit natürlich auch deutschland
selbstverständlich kann der präsident
der vereinigten staaten nicht in
deutschland nach lust und laune steuern
senken oder generell gesetze in
deutschland das ist selbstverständlich
nicht im rahmen seiner macht aber
dadurch dass die usa so eine große
nation sind riesig großes militär eine
riesengroße wirtschaft haben können sie
sehr wohl einfluss auf andere länder auf
der welt nehmen also es ist quasi ein
anderes land selbstverständlich eine
andere regierung aber es gibt auf jeden
fall große effekte die amerika auf
deutschland haben kann und deswegen
denke ich ist es auch wichtig als
deutscher teenager der vielleicht 14
oder 15 ist und dass jetzt sieht und
sich fragt warum ich das darüber
bescheid zu wissen was gestern passiert
ist und was eventuell für die zukunft
bedeutet denn es ist tatsächlich etwas
ist sehr sehr krasses passiert es hat
nämlich ungefähr niemand damit gerechnet
dass trump diese präsidentschaftswahl
gewinnt rampe ursprünglich nämlich
unternehmer und ist auch im fernsehen
aufgetreten
also es ist ungefähr so als würde stefan
raab sich in deutschland zur
bundeskanzler wahl aufstellen er würde
ihnen auch jeder vogel zeigen aber
tatsächlich hat trump ist jetzt
geschafft er ist präsident geworden und
wie gesagt die reaktion darauf im
internet sind relativ krass viele viele
leute haben auch schon gesagt dass sie
aus den staaten ausziehen wollen
präsident wird und er wurde jetzt
tatsächlich präsident zum beispiel der
schauspieler von breaking bad das kennt
ihr vielleicht der water white spielt
bryan cranston heißt er glaube ich er
hat selbst gesagt dass er aus den
vereinigten staaten ausziehen möchte
wenn donald trump präsident wird und ja
jetzt ist der präsident jetzt muss der
gute klang aus den vereinigten staaten
ausziehen als ihr merkt das ist schon
sehr sehr großes event und das betrifft
nicht nur einzelne leute selbst am
gestrigen abend war der sieg von trump
noch sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich ich
glaube die prognosen lagen bei ungefähr
27 prozent das heißt es ist sogar
relativ unwahrscheinlich hillary clinton
hatte dagegen 70 noch irgendwas hillary
clinton ist die kandidatin die gegen ihn
angetreten ist dass es eine frau die
schon sehr lange in der politik ist und
bei der jeder gedacht hat dass sie
eigentlich die besseren chancen hätte
letzten endes konnte sie das rennen aber
dann doch nicht für sich gewinnen das
ganze wahlsystem in den vereinigten
staaten ist relativ verrückt wenn man
das mit deutschlandvergleich wäre ich
interessiert wie das funktioniert habe
ich das in meiner beschreibung verlinkt
es ist nämlich relativ tricky ich glaube
in dem fall mit hillary clinton und
donald trump war es nämlich auch so dass
hillary clinton mehr stimmen bekommen
hat das heißt dass mehr bürger für
hillary clinton gestimmt haben aber
donald trump letzten endes präsident
wurde und das klingt eigentlich schon
verrückt also wissen wir wie das geld
liegt in der beschreibung dann die
nächste frage die sicher auch vielen von
euch stellt ok warum macht der typ jetzt
ein video über trump wie steht der
eigentlich zu trump ist ein tram fan die
leute die man auf twitter folgen haben
ja auch gesehen dass ich ein bild mit
trump kappeler gepostet habe das war
aber eher so ein gag weil ein kumpel von
mir die kappe dabei hatte und ich
einfach ich vorwurf hier gerne leute das
muss ich muss ich einfach zugeben ich
provoziere gerne leute und gerade an
meiner uni also ich studiere ja wo ich
dann den abend verfolgt habe da gab es
mal eine veranstaltung sind halt alle so
alle für clinton niemand ist für trump
und da finde ich es einfach witzig wenn
zumindest mal zwei drei leute für trump
sind selbst wenn es nur aus prinzip ist
damit irgendwann für trump ist man halt
irgendwie ein paar leute hat die mal was
anderes machen heißt ihr müsst euch
nicht aufregen weil ich die tram kappe
aufgehabt dabei ist es nicht dass ich
ein mensch bin ganz im gegenteil ich
komme nämlich aus
anderen richtung und zwar aber mein
lieblings kandidat für das
präsidentenamt in den vereinigten
staaten eigentlich bernie sanders des
senders halte ich es wahrscheinlich was
ist das jetzt für namens clinton und
trump gesagt dass die gegner angetreten
sind ja stimmt senders ist in den
vorwahlen gegen hillary clinton
angetreten die sich beide in der
gleichen partei und da ging es darum wer
für ihre partei antreten darf gegen
donald trump da hat senders ist leider
nicht geschafft und das hat nicht nur
mich sondern ich glaube sehr viele
jugendliche weltweit natürlich auch in
den vereinigten staaten geärgert und die
haben dann vielleicht deswegen einfach
weil sie sauer waren dann prompt gewählt
werden die nächste freie dierig
vielleicht stellt okay wer ist trump ich
habe noch nichts von ihm gehört so warum
machen alles und theater darum wer zum
beispiel mal auf twitter unter dem
hashtag election neid schaut werdet ihr
einige sehr sehr sehr traurige wütende
dauere aber auch sehr sehr fröhliche
post sehen also irgendwie scheint es die
leute sehr zu bewegen und es liegt zum
teil daran wer trump ist trump ist
nämlich ein kandidat der gesagt hat dass
er sich für die arbeiter also für die
einfachen leute die nicht so viel geld
verdienen in den vereinigen staaten
einsetzen möchte und damit und leider
auch mit ein paar sehr kritischen
aussagen wie zb das mexikaner kriminell
sind und so weiter und sofort hat er ja
er hat auf jeden fall viele viele leute
begeistert und letzten endes ist dadurch
präsident geworden und viele leute
rassen halt so krass aus als scheint
wirklich schon einige sehr sehr üble
sachen im vorfeld der wahl gesagt hat
zum beispiel hat er sich sehr negativ
über frauen geäußert das habt ihr
vielleicht gehört und er hat sich sehr
negativ gegenüber die migranten also
leute die in anderes land einwandern
geäußert und generell denken viele dass
trump ungefähr so dass das der übelste
kandidat ist den es jemals gab
dadurch ist es natürlich dann ganz
selbstverständlich dass so viele leute
ausrasten wenn dieser kandidat von dem
jeder am anfang gedacht hat dass er
überhaupt keine chance hat und auch
sowieso noch sehr sehr viele gedacht
haben dass er überhaupt nicht präsident
sein sollte weil das überhaupt nicht
kann weil er nicht dafür geeignet ist
weil er schnell ausrastet weil er nicht
wirklich viel weiß weil er einige sehr
problematische sachen gesagt hat wenn so
ein typ dann natürlich präsident wird
aus dem nichts und das haben nicht sehr
viele damit gerechnet wie gesagt dann
ist natürlich der aufschrei groß und
viele viele viele sehen den
weltuntergang 2016 oder 2017 jetzt schon
passieren denn trump ist jetzt erst mal
für vier jahre im amt
das heißt bis 2000 bis januar 2021 ist
er präsident der vereinigten staaten
und wenn noch mal gewählt wird
vielleicht sogar noch länger und ja die
vier jahre sind auf jeden fall eine zeit
die sehr sehr vielen leuten
bauchschmerzen bereitet jetzt ist eine
frage die man sich natürlich stellen
kann ok was passiert jetzt ich bin heute
morgen aufgewacht und tramper präsident
und die welt brennt noch nicht was ist
los alle sagen i wird müsste eigentlich
brennen es ist so dass momentan noch
barack obama das heißt der präsident vor
donald trump noch im amt ist und es ist
auch noch eine weile deren donald trump
wird erst am 20 januar 2017 in seinen
präsidenten am eingeführt bis dahin es
obama noch präsident deswegen hat sich
jetzt auch nicht von heute auf morgen
auf einen schlag viel verändert aber es
kann sich natürlich im januar sehr viel
verändern und noch mal die frage was
passiert jetzt geht jetzt die welt unter
nein die welt wie selbstverständlich
nicht unter und ich glaube auch dass die
welt nicht untergeht wenn donald trump
am 20 januar 2017 zum präsidenten wird
es ist ein sehr sehr schwieriges thema
und ich kann in dem video überhaupt
nicht alles sagen was ich gerne dazu
sagen möchte das geht einfach nicht aber
was man auf jeden fall sagen kann ist
das tram eine gewisse unsicherheit da
stellt trump steht dafür dass man die
dinge in der politik ganz anders macht
als man sie bisher gemacht hat und das
verunsichert sehr sehr viele leute
verständlicherweise der typ möchte ich
das gerne postbank ich glaube auch nicht
dass ich gar nicht so viele chancen
gegen die typen hab ja leute wenn ihr
euch jetzt fragt was war nicht der zweck
dieses videos der zweck dieses videos
war erst mal über das thema so bis hin
zu reden das bisschen anzuschneiden
kleinen denkanstoß zu geben und wenn ich
jetzt irgendwas vergessen habe in dem
video und ihre noch irgendwelche fragen
habt könnt ihr mir die einfach den
kommentaren stellen wie ich lese
natürlich die kommentare und beantwortet
die fragen und noch mal ich bin kein
trump gegner ich bin auch kein großer
traum fan ich bin einfach jemand denkt
dass das ein sehr sehr wichtiges thema
ist und wie gesagt wenn irgendwelche
fragen haben einfach ab damit in die
kommentare
ich hoffe euch hat es soweit gefallen
bis zum nächsten video